After a ton of hype about Captain Marvel's
powers, and her potential to take down Thanos,
why did the interstellar heroine have such
a tiny role in Avengers: Endgame?
The film's writers have revealed the real
reason.
Avengers: Infinity War teased the arrival
of Carol Danvers in a buzzworthy post-credits
scene, and Marvel Studios president Kevin
Feige said she would be the most powerful
character the Marvel Cinematic Universe had
ever seen.
Audiences were convinced she would be the
hero to finally bring Thanos to his knees.
But then, she didn't.
The film's co-screenwriters Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely addressed exactly why
in a recent deep-dive interview with The New
York Times.
It turns out, Captain Marvel actress Brie
Larson filmed her sequences for Avengers:
Endgame well before she shot her own solo
movie, and apparently before it even had a
completed script.
Which means that, if you just go by the shooting
schedules, Avengers: Endgame is technically
Carol Danvers' first appearance in the MCU.
Imagine that.
"Don't you think that's weird?"
"Definitely weird."
It would be difficult to write an arc for
Captain Marvel in Endgame when her own origin
story hadn't been pinned down yet.
What kind of person is Carol?
What drives her?
And what happens if her motivations between
movies somehow contradict each other?
Without the foundation of a solo story in
place, the Endgame team apparently decided
to dodge the problem entirely by not including
much of Captain Marvel in their movie.
Of course, none of those concerns got in the
way of Black Panther being a pretty major
player in Captain America: Civil War, but
things were a little bit different with that
film.
While the events of Civil War directly set
up the story of Black Panther, Endgame is
kind of the other way around, picking up with
a modern-day Carol while her story is already
in progress.
McFeely explained,
"We shot [Brie Larson] before she shot her
movie.
She's saying lines for a character 20 years
after her origin story, which no one's written
yet.
It's just nuts."
"We filmed Endgame before Captain Marvel.
We didn't even have a script yet, really,
for Captain Marvel."
"So how does that work?
How do you get into character?"
"It doesn't, but we figured it out."
McFeely also stated that the goal of Avengers:
Endgame wasn't to bring this hotshot new hero
into the mix and have her save the day.
Sure, she came to Tony Stark's rescue at the
top of the movie, and she also swooped in
to aid the Avengers at a critical moment in
the final battle, using her signature move
of body-slamming spaceships until they explode.
But beyond that Dragon Ball-level spectacle,
Captain Marvel just wasn't a major player
in the defeat of Thanos.
Instead, the writers smartly made the choice
to let the Avengers that we've come to know
for years take the spotlight, and in McFeely's
eyes, that's the way it was meant to be.
He said,
"Certainly, Captain Marvel is in [Endgame]
a little less than you would have thought.
But that's not the story we're trying to tell,
it's the original Avengers dealing with loss
and coming to a conclusion, and she's the
new, fresh blood."
Markus added that Captain Marvel also had
responsibilities elsewhere in the universe,
so of course she wouldn't be tied up with
the Avengers' big "Time Heist" mission.
Help out where she can?
Definitely.
Abandon her other commitments?
No way.
As McFeely noted,
"She's been in space nearly half her life.
She has obligations."
"Where the hell have you been all this time?"
"There are a lot of other planets in the universe,
and unfortunately, they didn't have you guys."
The weird thing is, with the Captain Marvel
movie mostly focusing on Carol becoming a
hero on Earth, audiences really have no idea
what Carol's interstellar obligations look
like.
Even weirder is that the writers of Endgame
didn't know much either.
McFeely and Markus' comments are fairly revealing
when it comes to the reality of moviemaking
at Marvel.
The studio maps out its film slate years in
advance, and uses each movie as an opportunity
to tease the next.
So far, it's worked exceedingly well.
But there's also a slight drawback to this
style of production, in that some films can
end up feeling a little hamstrung by having
to serve the needs of a broader narrative.
"What dialect?"
"Wakanada.
Wuh...wuh...Wakanda."
MCU filmmakers often have to work their movies
into the larger series in ways that sometimes
come off as a little tacked-on, or at least
hard to weave into a story.
This appears to be sort of what happened with
Captain Marvel, her solo film, and Endgame.
Now that Captain Marvel has come and gone,
fans can almost certainly look forward to
seeing a lot more of her in future films.
Kevin Feige even teased a second solo movie
when he told Screen Rant,
"The making of a first film is in some ways
a brainstorm on the future and on what can
be.
So what it will be again is not clear.
But what it could be is pretty amazing."
It's also been confirmed that the first few
years of Marvel's post-Endgame plan will be
officially rolled out in summer 2019, meaning
it won't be long before we find out what the
future is for Captain Marvel, and how big
a part she could play in the next phase of
the MCU.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.